we're of one cannot speak thereof one
must be silent this is probably one of
the most quoted additives of all time
and it was written by this man Ludwig
Wittgenstein a philosopher who by many
is considered the greatest of the 20th
century his role in the development of
analytic philosophy wasn't just central
but also pivotal for he devoted his life
in the examination of one of the most
cognitively demanding areas of human
interest that of language language
constitutes the most powerful tool we
have invented in order to communicate
with each other express ourselves and
evolve our perception but the essence of
words and the use of language can be
quite perplexing and can lead to
anomalies in the way we operate within
our social systems language is like a
living organism it changes it evolves it
has different forms and it can be
interpreted in different ways within
stein was fascinated by that and he
truly believed that with the use of
logic language can become more clearer
and more useful this was his obsession
but also what remanded him throughout
his life his ideas possessed a gravity
that felt unprecedented to almost all of
his readers most didn't understand him
but the ones that did opened their minds
to a world full of clarity and reason
the Kingston was born in 1889 in Vienna
Austria his family was one of the
richest in Europe and he headed the
fortune after his father died in 1913
money however wasn't of interest to him
and he gave away most of it to relatives
an artist's philosophy was according to
him the only work that gave him real
satisfaction he went to Cambridge in
1911 to study logic with a great
Bertrand Russell who after getting to
know him realized his genius his life
was quite tumultuous since his
involvement with logic almost drove him
mad
his mental anguish led him away from
Cambridge he went to Norway for a while
and then he volunteered for the
austro-hungarian army in the first world
war or changed him he became more
mystical and more ascetic and this could
be identified in his behavior in 1918 he
took military leave and he completed his
first important work Tractatus
logico-philosophicus the Tractatus was
published in 1922 in an attempt from
Vidkun Stein to present a solution to
the problems of philosophy that are
connected with language thought and
representation it is a short
mind-boggling and mind-bending work
where if you have managed to understand
it and even Wittgenstein himself had
trouble making sense of the purport of
some of his statements later in his life
the way he writes is quite austere in
that he uses small sentences but with
great intensity some of them are almost
incomprehensible for a reader not
accustomed with the topic the sense of a
proposition is its agreement and
disagreement with the possibilities of
the existence and non-existence of the
atomic facts empirical reality is
limited by the totality of objects the
boundary appears again the totality of
elementary propositions others however
whose meaning and no whereof one cannot
speak thereof one must be silent we feel
very even if all possible scientific
questions be answered the problems of
life have still not been touched at all
ethics and aesthetics are one the main
point that he wants to address is what
can really be expressed through language
and to what extent philosophical
problems have a reason to exist
world thought and language that
intertwined and vidiian Stein manages to
create a philosophical system that
identifies how all three are connected
through the use of logical propositions
he develops an advanced technical
framework that investigates the limit of
world thought and language in other
words distinguishes between sense and
nonsense
in a nutshell he puts forth a heroic
attempt to explain that the way we
approach languages is wrong and that
especially talking philosophy is bound
to be a senseless procedure thoughts and
utterances are true when they map onto
the world saying this is a pineapple on
a table make sense it is a fact but
saying this is a very pleasant pineapple
is senseless
since this proposition is open to
multiple interpretations it is the use
of the word in our way of life that ifs
meaning to our words and not how we feel
inside about it if a lion could speak we
wouldn't be able to understand it
because we can't know what its world is
like Wittgenstein is point is to show
that misunderstanding of how language
works leads to pseudo problems and that
most problems of philosophy are like
that are you saying there are no
philosophical problems linguistic but
medical ethical logistic and religious
problems but there are no genuine
philosophical problems you're
trivializing philosophy philosophy is
just a byproduct of misunderstanding
language I have searched a lot for a
meaningful interpretation of
Wittgenstein's words in my regard the
philosopher provokes us in order to be
more careful with the accurate use of
language since its senseless use can
lead to many interpersonal and
perceptual problems in our paradigms
moreover his last paragraphs illuminate
a sense of nihilism since he urges us to
not take seriously any of his words my
propositions are the lucidity or in this
way he who understands me finally
recognizes the must
when he has climbed out through them on
them or rhythm he must so to speak throw
away the ladder after he has climbed up
on it
he must surmount these propositions then
he sees the world the rightly whereof
one cannot speak thereof one must be
silent a great exegesis to that aphorism
was one from the great Alan Watts in
which he suggests that the whole task of
philosophy is to really get rid of
itself the whole task of philosophy is
really to get rid of itself I mean in
rather the same way the task of a doctor
is to put himself out of business
because he never succeeds it because
people keep getting sick but if he was
100 percent successful he had lose all
his patients because they wouldn't be
ill any more and so in the same way a
philosopher of this kind is very rarely
out of business because there are still
always people with what we might call
intellectual sicknesses bothered by
fantastic and non-existent problems the
years passed and didn't Stein changed
he abandoned philosophy for a while and
he occupied himself with other
activities like teaching at an
elementary school in rural Austria and
designing the famous Vidkun stein house
none of this made him happy he
eventually returned to his original
calling and started teaching philosophy
in Cambridge in 1929 abandoning
philosophy for a while seemed to have
had a huge impact on Whittier Stein
since most of his former abuse changed a
lot of people refer to the period before
the chains as le vidiians time period
and to the one after as later
Wittgenstein period what marks the
transition of the one period to the
other is the total rejection of
dogmatism with instant himself referred
to his early work as dogmatic and worked
hard so that he could be better
understood the culmination of this
change reflected on his magnum opus
titled philosophical investigations in
it he concerns himself with the concepts
of meaning understanding propositions
logic mathematics states of
consciousness and other things still
language go occupies a very central role
in his admiration but
abandon the idea the language is used to
describe a picture of the world the
relationship between language and the
world is quite untidy there are many
different ways we can do with language
many different language games it can
stand like to call them the meaning of a
word is relative to the language game
that we play the real task of the
Philosopher's to sort out this language
games in the close analysis of the
language in widget were posed
philosophical puzzles arise because we
tend to mix up one language game with
another for example people puzzle over
the nature of something they call the
soul but this may just be because
they're thinking of the soul along the
lines of a physical object they're
confusing one way of talking with
another the job of philosophy is to sort
out these language games exactly well
they're all perfectly in orders they are
philosophy in no sense can question them
philosophy leaves everything exactly as
it is every explanation is after all the
hypothesis posing grandiose
philosophical questions producing as a
mental cramp a philosopher cannot cure
the cramp completely but his or her role
can definitely prove therapeutic Vadim
Stein died in 1951 and philosophical
investigations was published
posthumously before dying shattered tell
them I've had a wonderful life
his main issue and the one that agonized
him the most was the importance of
claritin thought don't for heaven's sake
be afraid of talking nonsense but you
must pay attention to your nonsense as
he used to say there is a lot of mental
dirt in this world enough to disorient
our already disoriented mind and he
viewed clarity as the only antidote
despite his genius he was doubtful of
most of his ideas and he states that
explicitly and all of his works he knew
that what he wrote was difficult to
understand but what he actually wanted
was to stimulate someone to thoughts of
his own Wittgenstein's work was a plea
for reason a plea for better
communication a plea for more clarity if
you could see that after all most of us
find it hard to see what is right in
of our eyes hi everyone I won't lie to
you
Wittgenstein always constituted an
enigmatic personality for me when I
first laid my hands on the Tractatus
I was shocked I couldn't understand a
single word and I thought that he was
probably an overrated philosopher but
then I delve deep into content produced
about him and when I finally managed to
peer into his mind his world mesmerized
me I consider language and his proper
used one of the most critical issues of
our time
Wittgenstein was obsessed with that and
even though his ideas are hard to grasp
when explained properly can prove
incredibly useful today's giveaway will
be the legendary philosophical
investigations since many of you don't
have an Instagram account we will
experiment with different rules today if
you want to take part in the giveaway
please like this video subscribe get
notifications and comment below why you
want the book or maybe suggest the topic
for a future video or to be honest any
insightful comment will do I will
message the winner and I will announce
he more hair in my Instagram account in
a week from now so if you're using
Instagram please follow me there and
mention your Instagram user ID in your
comment below
we'd like to all of you take care see
you soon
[Music]